and pairs of backed anti-strike
legislation which is aimed at enforcing
minimum service levels for some sectors
during strikes it's cleared the commons
but not without criticism including from
our next guest conservative MP and
former Minister for brexit opportunities
Jacob Reese mogg hi hello good morning
thanks for joining us why are you
against it I'm in favor of the principle
of the bill I think it's good bill I
think what it's trying to do is sensible
the point I was making last night was
about the structure of the bill which
Ron setting out in detail what it is
seeking to do has a very widespread
Henry VII power which allows the
government to change
in the reign of Henry VII the bill was
passed through Parliament Knack
Department that allowed rule by
proclamation rather than by a proper
parliamentary process so this is the
slang term for law that allows the
government to change acts of parliament
which are our highest form of law by
order rather than by a full Act of
Parliament and so Clause 3 of this bill
is essentially a very wide Henry VII
power and this is not good legislative
practice it's very unpopular in the
hearts of Lords and governments pass
better laws that are less susceptible
judicial review when they set out the
detail of what they're trying to do so
my complaint was a technical and
constitutional one about the structure
of the bill why do you think brexit's
going well oh I think brexit is going
well for a whole range of reasons I
can't give you one to start with 191
billion pounds that we've saved by not
being part of the eu's covered bailout
that would have been our share of that
two trillion Euro scheme I'll give you
another one that insurance is cheaper
because we're no longer subject to the
when there's no longer subject to the
v-nock regulation which was an extra
charge on insurance for
um lawnmowers which was quite
unnecessary uh solvency too potentially
100 billion pounds of extra money going
into the UK economy at the gene editing
Bill passing through Parliament at the
moment to make our agriculture more
efficient 63 increase in the catch of
cod in the last year and the benefits
Northern Ireland protocol the board are
basically in the Irish sea is the
inevitable consequence of brexit wasn't
it worth it for that no no it's not the
inevitable consequence of brexit at all
and if you look at the Northern Ireland
protocol it says two very important
things one that it's temporary and is to
be changed subject to technological
abilities to have no border and secondly
it mustn't override the Good Friday
Belfast agreement that is primary so the
Good Friday agreement outranks the
protocol seems to me the Northern
Ireland protocol is failing and needs to
be funded mentally reformed if not
abandoned okay so why if it's so
straightforward and so simple has that
not already happened well the
government's just got to get on with it
there's a an act of parliament a bill
sorry that has been through the House of
Commons that is waiting its report stage
in the House of Lords and I don't
understand why the government hasn't
brought it forward in the House of Lords
for its reports today so you don't think
that there will be a border in the Irish
scene there must not be a border in the
Irish see we are a United Kingdom and
the Northern Ireland protocol recognizes
that we're a single United Kingdom and
the Northern Ireland is in our customs
area and is a fundamental path to United
Kingdom so this would not be
inconsistent with Northern protocol and
IMF report out today seems to suggest
that brexit is not going well UK is
behind its counterparts in the G7 group
of advanced Nations and the only country
to suffer a year of declining GDP you're
saying that's not nothing to do with
well first of all this is a forecast and
when was the Army forecast last right
so you've got to understand that
forecasts are not historic fact and this
is really important because we get the
same with the ABR the ABR week ago do
you agree with the government Minister
this morning who says that they're often
wrong and he doesn't believe it well I
didn't hear the government Minister but
whoever said that was a share genius and
he has my full support but the ABR gets
his figures wrong the whole time I I
hear Radio 4 is getting rid of its um
racing tips it might as well get rid of
the obr forecast
broadcasters on this channel thank you
well I'm just saying that tips aren't
right but the ABR is even less accurate
than the radio for racing tips so I
dispute that but but I'd also point out
what the IMF has said about this which
is that it's high taxation and the
increase in interest rates no we were
slow with the increase in interest rates
they should have come sooner because
inflation was already running at a high
level and the bank of England was very
slow to deal with that much slower than
the Federal Reserve and that may be a
reason why America has a chance to
recover faster because it got on with
its monetary policy more swiftly but
also we have the highest tax burden in
70 years and that is not good for
economic growth and I thought you're
going to say that the trust squatting
was a better option economically no I
think there was a mistake there which
was
um in not following the tax cuts with
cuts and expenditure because the state
is too big and if the state takes too
large a share of your economy your
economy cannot grow
it's not the productive bid what earns
the money that pays for everything is
the private sector not the public sector
so if you have too big a weight of the
public sector on the economy your
economy will have sluggish growth where
would you start to cut well when I was a
minister in the cabinet office we were
looking at reducing civil service by 91
000 which would have been an important
saving so there are savings that can be
found yeah savings within the NHS and
the defense budget I think within the
NHS it's a question as the health
secretary is pointing towards their
savings to be had in ways of treating
people that use the money more
effectively and there it's a question of
reducing the level of increase rather
than actually cutting the overall budget
the best period I think of increase in
productivity in the NHS was between 2010
and 2015 when the nhs's budget was
Frozen in real terms and then you've got
productivity increases which what we
really need I don't know if you saw
recently across the public sector as a
whole a seven and a half percent decline
in productivity which seems to me to be
strongly correlated in this particularly
NHS problem with working from home so we
need better productivity and public
services and that is getting people back
in the office to do their jobs
um the NHS is not delivering the service
that people want and I think it's really
important that we're treating a
socialist politician has been putting
forward proposals for reform of the NHS
and that when he mentions exactly
include privatization impact as far as
Robinson well GP is a private anyway as
you know so the NHS has always drawn on
the private sector the drug companies
are private companies so the NHS does
not exist in Splendid isolation from the
rest of the economy let me put it
another way should we have to pay to see
the GP
um I don't think that's necessary I
think it'd be nice if we could see the
GP but interestingly this is by surgery
I was had a meeting in my own
constituency and one of my constituents
was saying to me at the GP surgery they
go to just on the edge of bath they get
seen straight away and get a fantastic
service so it is possible in some GPU
surgeries question organization much
more than money
prime minister I think he's doing
perfectly confidently that's not ringing
indoors look I made no bones about the
fact I thought Boris Johnson was a
better prime minister and I wanted him
to remain do you think he'll be a good
chairman Boris Johnson
I think he would be a brilliant chairman
but he's not going to be chairman if you
look at the best chairman of the
conservative party they've been people
like Chris Patton and tussle Parkinson
who are both very close to the leader
and also charismatic so the person Rishi
sunak needs is somebody who's both close
to him and somebody who is also very
charismatic listen Nadim so how are we a
good gym Nadine was actually a very good
chairman highly competent Chapman do you
think it was the right decision to get
rid of him well I I think that the
circumstances were such in the report
from the Independent advisor was such
that it was impossible for Nadim to stay
what sort of problems is the prime
minister wishes United are building for
himself so we see allegations against
Dominic Raab um more than a dozen
um civil servants complaining that he is
a bully that's being investigated Gavin
Williamson being sacked
um
all adding to an hour of sleeves around
this government
well I mean a labor MP had to stand down
from his seat and there was a bad action
because he had behaved in an unsuitable
manner within his office if I remember
the details correctly and that was only
last year if you take a parliament of
650 people there will inevitably be some
people who don't behave as well as they
should and that is always an issue for
all prime ministers and all these
departures he was talking about maybe a
couple of dozen people around the
academy yeah well I I
I think we've got to be slightly careful
about the bullying allegations you did
indeed quite quite rightly yeah um but
also we mustn't be too snowflakey about
it but people need to be able to say
this job has not been done well enough
and needs to be done better
um that
good Public Services it's a snowflake
it's a it's a very
difficult line to charge it is not a
straightforward issue uh in most cases
it is how did somebody react what did
somebody say is it reasonable to demand
from senior and well-paid professionals
a level of good service and then you
have to judge whether that line has been
overstepped but I I do worry that we are
getting a bit snow flaky about this
just hearing actually my producer in my
ear as I'm chatting to you the lib Dems
have just said that they want a Dominic
Rob to be suspended for the duration of
the investigation
well the lib dams have to say things
like that because otherwise no one pays
attention to them that's
me can drink uh I I think it's
completely sensible that the Lord
Chancellor remains fully in post whilst
the investigation takes place and the
Prime Minister then makes a judgment as
to whether or not these allegations are
serious or not I thought Boris Johnson
was absolutely right to keep pretty
Patel in office it was an exceptionally
good Home Secretary when there are
allegations against her from a home
office that wasn't getting on with what
she wanted let's end on a lighter note
should we I read in the paper this
morning going back to brexit um that
rhinos can't breed
all your fault that we don't have enough
rhinos the elephant pector Tron
considered right to the circus or she
went with the trumpety Trump Trump trump
the EU has set up rules if you noticed
it was all about our animals going to
the continent
if the EU doesn't want our Rhine is the
EU will have to live without our rhinos
apparently it's become cheaper to send
our animals to New Zealand and the
United States so we will work with
people who want to work with us and that
is the lesson of brexit It's Always
fascinating to talk to you how's your
pleasure thank you very much thank you
so much appreciated thank you